vous serez attirés par la blancheur
éclatante du tuffeau égayant les façades
des anciennes maisons et des châteaux
prestigieux
l'idée de ce guide est né de la volonté
de croiser les regards celui du grand
public à celui du géologue sur le val de
loire
la géologie est perçu comme une science
austère et pourtant ce qu'il faut faire
c'est pas parlé directement d'orange ou
de pierre qui font souvent fuir les gens
mais plutôt parler de ce qu'ils
connaissent donc nos vignobles les
paysages les bâtiments pour qu'on a
utilisé tel type de matériau pas un
autre pourquoi ce vignoble en a
plusieurs types de vins pour illustrer
son propos nicolas charle empruntent les
images qui nous sont familières
prenez par exemple la cathédrale sainte
croix d'orléans le pont george de 5 ou
la loire et son banc de sable
si on reprend les monuments le pont la
cathédrale le géologue nuit va voir les
matériaux qui la constituent pour ce qui
est du pont george 2,5 encore de la
cathédrale c'est quelqu'un de gauche qui
eux me est âgé de 20 millions d'années
quant à la loire est bien le jeune homme
va la voir comme un vecteur donc de soi
de ressources ou encore comme un vecteur
de risques naturels notamment concernant
les inondations le val de loire est le
deuxième producteur de vin après la
région bordelaise
grâce au savoir faire des vignerons
certes mais aussi grâce au sous sol
prenez par exemple s'en sert les vins
dit de terre blanche qui eux se
développe sur des terrains du jurassique
donc plusieurs centaines de millions
d'années un qui sont plus des terrains
calcaires et qui vont donner des vins
assez fort et c'est justement ce vin de
terre'blanche qui est très recherché on
s'en sert et que ces patchs ou prenez
encore les matériaux qui ont permis de
construire des habitations
le tuffeau c'est une range très poreuse
donc idéal pour monter en altitude pour
les cathédrales ou pour les châteaux est
également très tendre le guide val de
loire de sancerre à saumur fourmille
d'anecdotes et d'illustration il est
très documenté